[Music]
there are some crazy trends sprouting in
2021
uh already yeah well i have one green by
trend like cool company hashtags i like
those
like which ones like use our product and
let us know like how cool it is
the whole hashtag oh yeah everyone
hashtag everyone does that well
is that marble should start doing that
guys you guys are late yep
tell us how much you liked our barbell
shirts
exactly dude these companies are so
delusional with this [ __ ] it's so funny
my favorite trending meme so far that
happened already is the bernie one
oh he's sitting everywhere oh with the
mitts it grew so fast
like within like two hours after the
inauguration that is so funny
no but uh well this one i'm talking
about is a facial hair
trend that men are doing oh is it the
roller the spiky roller and it helps
grow your facial hair
no that derma roller is that that makes
you grow your facial hair that sounds
like a scam
there's a ad i don't know how they
targeted me probably i don't grow facial
hair
but so i probably need this but you put
like the serum
and then it has like the spiky thing and
you just go across and i guess it like
activates the pores and it helps you
grow oh yeah
yeah yeah no this one's actually the way
men are are shaping their facial hair
oh try to guess braiding
like what kind so so okay so we have
mustaches
right we have goatees i thought the
go-to
for the beard is always try to make that
jawline like that damn builds your
shirt shape thingy i don't know what
it's called the lineup
i don't know and then there's like a
chin strap yeah that
a chin strap or there's like um
handlebar
mustache those are cool curly mustache
these are almost
what about the kung fu master where this
one's really long
it looks like a catfish that's another
one what about like the blackbeard one
where like he just
braids him and then he lights individual
braids on fire oh wow
why is he lighting it on fire i don't
know maybe because it makes him look
more badass
doesn't it like burn up that's how
blackbeard died he caught him
he caught on fire yeah
but anyway no it looks like this what
the [ __ ]
they're calling it the monkey tail beard
shut the [ __ ] up that's a real thing
when you say trend you mean like two
people did it or oh i have many
photos who did that who does that
these people but what does it mean so
it's just a
it's a shape of how they're having their
facial hair it's
oh it's like a monkey tail it looks like
a wave kind of this is one of those
things where i look at the picture and i
go
why people you know it's like one of
those things you scream out loud
is he a ginger on the chin or is it pink
he kool-aided it he decoolated hair
and then there's that one it's very
confusing to look at
that i mean it looks like a question
mark right yeah that's why people are
like it's like the kind of beard that
the riddler would grow out
it's exactly what i thought it's like a
hook yeah it's like a hook
or like the fishing fishing clipper yeah
the fishing rod that angle doesn't look
that bad
yeah cause you can't see the ball part
that's how like widespread this is you
have this many photos of it already yeah
exactly that's how i'm like this is a
trend guy yeah i don't like it
he got a head shot with it he would he
didn't do it for like that quick minute
that monkey tail looks striped oh
because he has
some grays in there shouldn't they like
make their hair more into like a monkey
shape then so i actually look like a
tail
oh continue the spiral up here oh like
it's the butt yeah so it looks like
we have the butt cheek right here shave
one little hole right there on top of
the butthole
and dye it pink that's crazy
i know we know who started it or is well
so the one who made it popular is this
dude
so he's uh cause he's on sports ball
player
so mike mike something mike monkey
mike mike fears
yeah and he plays for the a the oakland
the oakland team and it literally says
there's a's all over his whole body yeah
okay no but i'm telling you the city oh
i see
the oakland monkeys the oakland aids
athletics athletics thank you
well you watched borton uh yes i
have to my husband is very into sports
so we're an angels fan or i am what
about football
um chargers oh i'm so sorry
that's devastating chargers usc
um and then the ducks she has to watch
chargers games with him
yeah i even have a jersey oh are you
into it or
or is are you just four i'm into usc
like the college ones they're a little
more entertaining than um college is
better to watch than the
pros oh yeah oh hell no i will fight you
hell i can't talk to you i mean there's
no defense in college football
it's just offense what do you like to
watch about college football she's like
their butts are better
yeah what do you like about college
football they're around my age no i'm
just kidding um
yeah what is it i like going to the
games
oh that's cool though you get to go
obviously because of the pandemic but
the games are way funner than watching
it because it's more like school when
i'm at home i'm just walking around i
don't really care for it
um but once you're at the game you're at
the stadium you're telling me the energy
is crazier than oh
yeah as a non-sport person i've heard
that college football
games are better because they try harder
oh because they're trying to make it
yeah because from what i heard as
someone who does not watch sports
uh i heard that people like in the
professional world at least
no matter what you're like making money
win or lose but like the
yeah in college you're trying to win so
you can get noticed and stuff like that
yeah that's how you
guys are there why do you think college
football sucks i don't really think it
sucks
i just don't enjoy it as much because i
know like every [ __ ] player in the
nfl like i love all that [ __ ] yeah
you know the backstory i don't know all
that stuff as much so yeah but wouldn't
it be more entertaining because you're
like
okay he is a good player there he's like
number or top five
pick and two like you you that stuff
kind of bleeds in
but i just don't understand like the
playoff system is [ __ ] nuts
like all that i'm just i'm confused by
college ball
you know what makes it all fun gambling
let's see that's fun
yeah or fantasy football isn't that a
form of gambling or something
don't you put money on the real gambling
the real yeah sports betting
like you could go to vegas and you could
bet like how long
they're gonna sing the anthem for so
from the start of it
from the start of the [ __ ] game you
could bet every single part like
how many hot dogs fall on the floor like
seriously i bet you no one had a bet for
this
i know right like imagine there was a
bet for like the craziest facial hair
there might be now honestly to the apes
yeah
in a sequel for uncut gems we're going
to see it yeah
is it possible to do a double monkey
tail does it like delete that no because
then they'll just be the full thing
well wouldn't that just be a mustache
connected to a goatee go
tb right sideburns yeah and then when
they're all pieces together oh that's
just appears
no actually it'll just be a circle like
like
it's like a circle it's like a circle
connected to the
what do you call this part sideburn chin
yeah yeah this one no yeah they do this
one and then they
the rhyme that's what i think of it as
the ryan dude that would be hilarious
it's like a
oh right here and then it just goes up
like this
is that supposed to be funny or like
that's like a serious thing now
i think it's looks like he's taking
pretty serious it looks like he's taking
it pretty seriously he's also bald too
so picture his head bald with oh he has
no hair
yeah yeah it's just this like what do
y'all think of what do girls think about
facial hair specifically youtube what do
you think about this mustache of course
is this
i hate it yeah all facial hair oh you
don't like it over the loop
no well for me i mean like casey when we
first started dating he had like he grew
a tiny little thing right here
full patch yeah a little yeah that a
little tiny why did he just grow this
you want to have an extremely punchable
face
stupid that's what the soul patch does
he wants to look like a french villain
so back then he had he had a piercing
here oh
he's saying clothes or something and
then he just grew like a tiny little
patch
which i like to fill that void that he
once had i guess like i think he liked
having something here
i don't know but i liked that but then
now he shaves it
and it's clean every time it's like
growing out the stubble it really hurts
me when we kiss because it's like really
sharp it actually like punctures my skin
sometimes but so for that reason like
i'm just like
but then just visually is there
disconnect between what you like
visually
and then like obviously like getting
eaten out or kissed is different
yeah there's a disconnect right what is
the difference between getting eaten out
your kids
they don't like the stubble they're both
little i see yeah there's no difference
you're right they're like get that
facial hair out of my [ __ ]
it's like you need to go [ __ ] smooth
actually no i wouldn't mind
facial hair okay so he's like grow out
that mustache for my [ __ ] it's my face
that hurts especially down here because
then it ends up like
it ends up like give me like a rash go
shave your face for my makeout session
yes grow it out to eat my [ __ ] tomorrow
yes love it
okay let's do that women are simple yes
red
input so it's like you start the session
making out and then as he's going down
you go away and you go
no no he's not we start the session down
there and then we move oh
so you don't mind mixing your your honey
juice with your lip juice it tastes
great
yeah what about you when you like
mustaches on your [ __ ]
the way you said it you're like this is
[ __ ] nice is this appropriate you are
my boss he's my boss too we talk about
something uh okay
this is knowing bart it's a sad
experience
yeah i don't know i i i know that does
adam have a mustache
okay the thing with him is um he looks
smooth
yeah so i didn't even notice until he
like
completely shaves and i'm like oh you
have a nice little baby face
but i never noticed that he was growing
facial hair it just doesn't grow that
long for him
oh yeah so it's just like little patches
of hair
but then once he shaves i'm like oh
shoot you you had hair
dude maybe this cat he has his face like
this but then his balls are like the
other way
so it completes a look if you could see
him yeah that'd be cool
how would it be that's true like no so
it's like
so because it's
like a treble clef and a bass clef or
maybe his penis is just curved and then
he's
it follows it follows it right out and
then the patch of hair is up here so
then what's the
what's the shape just like a big like a
little like upside down question mark
almost like a nike like a nike switch
like a shoe
that's cool like a lower leg i could do
something with the bottom i can't do
anything up here you can also see he has
a hairy chest
so i'm like i wonder what he has his
ideas for his chest are
do you like hairy chests no no no
all the hairy chest guys out there are
sad but in the 70s they were like
you probably were like [ __ ] yeah right
and the 70s hair was just everywhere
right right
thanks to brooklyn everywhere yeah for
like girls everything everywhere
i like a haircut anyone do you but just
for me personally
hairy chest gold chain and uh like one
that's what steve would have been oh and
then also the handle bar massage
you like when the chains floating on the
hair i love that [ __ ] in the 70s you
would have been a porn producer style
look
oh a guy that lives maybe in miami with
a gold chain on his neck
those guys are sick yeah i can kind of
see steve in that style thank you
like visually though like seeing this
like some hair pop
out of his chest like it doesn't gross
me out it's sexy
yeah it is it's sexy how confusing but
that's
what you just asked right do you like
chestnuts
remember they said they don't like hairy
chests but now it's kind of sexy
no no hold on it's because of the spiral
face i don't want
i don't want to like have my man with a
hairy chest but looking at this
yeah it sucks like the little unbuttoned
shirt and then
like kind of showing it's like looking
at a nice car but you don't want to
drive it
right makes a lot of sense to me it
doesn't because when i see a nice ass i
want to touch it
well but i'm not allowed to because
there's no permission obviously i have
to ask for consent that's right there
has to be an equivalent where they can
understand this right well yeah what is
it that you would like it but you don't
like it because how can you go ooh and
then he takes off his shirt you're like
i didn't want to touch it if we could
figure if we could figure this out
we could solve the men to women gap that
is this is
you guys help us out in the comments how
do we how do i explain this because off
the top of my head i can't because i
feel like everything i like
i would want it yeah i don't quite
understand that but think of it think of
it like a like a car with really stiff
suspension think about that as a daily
driver on like terrible roads
right yes that's not very comfortable
but at that same time you're like
you maybe you could look at it on the
racetrack or try that one time okay yeah
nelson's getting it
he's a one-night stand to you guys oh
like you don't wanna you don't wanna
marry him but
a one-night stand with a little bit that
meme where that guy is holding his
girlfriend's hand and he's like
looking and then the girl's like what
are you looking at you know
is it like how joe brought donuts in
today but then most of us didn't have
any because we're trying to be good but
we would be like donuts yes
okay i see kind of like that okay but
but i would have ate it if i
wanted to eat it but because you're
trying to be okay is it because you're
married
like if casey had hairy chest i wouldn't
like it
but it fits this wouldn't want him to
have it
but but if i saw casey with a hairy
chest i'm like oh that's sexy
but if i'm gonna [ __ ] you i'd rather you
just have to go shave
i see so you gotta get them with the
hairy chest and before bed
you shave so guys the the rule here is
make sure you have a razor gotta lie and
trick them
make sure you have a razor attract them
with the hair and when you get into the
bedroom
shave it off there's women out there
that love hairy chest
and but then they're the opposite when
they see it they want to see a guy
without him no yeah they wanted to grow
you better grow on me they see it smooth
here they're like oh that's a little
sexy
you better grow at me in three months
we're the only weird ones i can only
speak for
myself rank speak for herself we don't
know
i am just as confused as when this
[Music]
started
[Music]
you